Council adopted reform of the statute
the court of justice this reform offers
a sustainable long-term solution when it
comes to the challenges the court is
facing and it will allow the court to
work effectively speedily in the years
to come will help the Union work
according to the rule of law the
Luxembourg presidency also made enormous
progress on the European public
prosecutor today we have made also
significant progress with a very broad
support on the proposal on the table the
European public prosecutor will allow us
to enforce our zero-tolerance policy on
fraud against the EU budget new news app
or getting close with Parliament and the
Commission to our objective common
objectives we want to offer an effective
be in our system in the EU respecting
rights and fundamental liberties member
states constructively have said they
agree on in the six months retention
time they said they want to build in
intra-eu flights and non carrier
economic operators we also looked at
angle of combating terrorism conclusions
we've signed up to systematic checks at
external borders and also discussed
boosting of exchange of information so
that we have enough intelligence on
threat ministers reached a political
agreement on the Europol regulation this
deform makes Europol more operational
more accountable and more effective it
can be the hub of our intelligence
sharing in the context of
counterterrorism the concise hit attack
council has tried to take measures in
order to improve the management of the
migrant crisis so we worked on
relocation returns at readmission and
the management of external borders
the Greek authorities have made
substantive efforts when it comes to the
hot spot all Member States today said
they supported the Schengen area
Schengen will only work if the rules are
respected we have to remedy shortcomings
in controls of external borders and i
think that the deployment of rabbits in
greece is particularly important in this
respect I ears all ministers to step up
to speed up the relocation process from
Greece and Italy and to offer the
necessary resources that will help them
make all the hot spots fully operational
it is only by fully implementing all
elements of the relocation mechanism and
I emphasize the word all that the system
will work for everyone